I get a kick out of seeing what kind of
gags they made and which ones they they
want to go for and which ones they just
sort of lay and wait for it's pretty
clear what kind of timing did they have
to do a short like this what would be
the the schedule on something like this
a month six like a six to eight week
schedule at least had Warner Brothers
they were reading that at least at
Disney the director they would have what
they called the music room where the
director would sit with the musician and
the layout artists and they would work
through the timing and the music kind of
at the same time so the music would be
written hand-in-hand as the animation
would be timed out and animated so if an
animator decided you know I need another
seven frames or two frames or whatever
they'd have to go back to the musician
he'd have to change his score in the
case of anyway the Pixar films we don't
even we just times stuff sort of blindly
to whatever we think and then folks like
Michael come in and have to work what
are you doing yeah exactly so you do all
the music yeah which I know we talked
about like in married life that sequence
in up wanting to do that just for timing
reasons it didn't work out but we were
hoping to do music first right and then
animate to that but most of the time
it's the opposite never how fun would
that be to be able to do both at the
same time oh it would be great and and
it's you know it would be a luxury that
we generally it's nice to think about
but you know schedules being as they are
it rarely is practical the other thing I
wanted to mention about when you listen
to these things and you know again I
stress that I did grow up on Warner
Brothers cartoons and Tom and Jerry
you know the MGM stuff listening to the
level of musicianship that these guys
the musicians themselves were
unbelievable I mean you're listening to
these recordings you might as well be
listening to some great symphony
recording of these guys and these guys
would just come in and pound it out
right there was no rehearsal for this
thing they just look at alright let's do
it you know
they're kind of like the cowboys of the
music of the music world you know just
just put it down and we'll do it and and
you know as I mentioned before these
were the studio orchestras these like
the last one would obviously be the MGM
Orchestra that's mostly a piano track
that was the guy who played piano for
the MGM GM Orchestra
it's pretty cool plane yeah I'm just
looking at the next one which is one of
my favorites you know the the the the
back-alley uproar
that's brilliant it's pretty great and
it has it does have the Hungarian
Rhapsody in it as well which we'll find
but but not in the sense that you've
seen it here you're gonna get a snippet
of about oh geez it you you have Rossini
you have list you have Sammy Cahn and
Brahms you forgot you know John f bar if
you've got any you know 20 different
things going on in this song but you're
getting like seconds of each one and you
understand as we watch it it's just for
me it's a real Carl stalling
extravaganza yeah do you think he would
had a TD you know if you see pictures
him he just looks like this nice guy who
came into work every day but he had
something going on but I will say went
to his music basically was very simple
it wasn't very complicated and it was it
was orchestrated at least in the later
years by Milt Franklin who was the one
who did what's opera doc and you can
hear the same kind of a sound but a very
different style I heard a recording when
I was working on Tiny Toons since we had
to try and do his style there was a
recording of him doing the William Tell
Overture really fast enough dump the
dump open and they work and after it's
all over you hear this voice come from
the booth very good I have all of the
original recordings to the Scott Bradley
stuff for Tom and Jerry all of those and
it's you can hear very similar kinds of
comments and stuff and in what they have
in the Tom and Jerry you notice and you
got it well you got one in there this
little point what do you ever you'll
pull out the whisker and I believe and
maybe Melinda can tell me if I'm wrong I
think it's a violin someone pulling the
violin string just plucking it and wait
kind of a thing kind of a sound but it's
it's incredible to hear them do these
and on those recordings you can actually
hear them going okay let's do a couple
of these blogs and there's there any one
is it Carl stalling project it's an
outtake of a
you know player playing the rhythm wrong
and you hear I think it's Milt Franklin
who was the conductor as well right and
he goes no dananananana
and he's like he does the right rhythm
for a guy and there's really sort of
annoying nasally voice most the time
they got it right no comedy is a serious
business
you
you